What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. Tonight there is
a very interesting study that I heard
about like, I don't know, eight, seven,
eight years ago and at first I just
really dismissed it because there were
certain things about it that I was like,
you know what? This seems like it kind
of takes away free will or, you know, no
man knows and all these kinds of things.
But the more I start looking into this,
I'm starting to see more merit in it.
Things are starting to line up. Things
that are happening in the political
world and the religious world.
It's getting close, guys. I believe that
Jesus is coming soon and I have my good
friend Wendy on here. She's done a great
study on this and I cannot wait for you
to get into this. So, thank you for
coming on, Wendy.
Yeah, I'm so glad to be here. Thanks for
having me, Mikey. Yeah, man. I think
this Is this the first time you've been
on Candid Truth?
Yeah. Oh, wow. Okay, so you've been on
Little Light and Strange Normal. I know
that we've done shows together but never
on Candid Truth. This is awesome.
So, you actually got to share this
presentation at your church recently,
right?
I did, yeah. It was about two weekends
ago. There's a good group of us that
talk about the cosmic week, so they were
excited and I was like, yeah, let's do
it.
That's very interesting. So, the cosmic
week, there's probably people in here
that have never heard of that.
Um I I guess we don't want to kind of
just burst the bubble without going
through it. So, you want to just like
Yeah.
Like get into it and not talk about it.
Yeah, let's do it. Ready or not, here we
go. Wait, this is part two. Is that
true?
It is part two. So, the message I did
before this was Ready or Not part one.
And it just really talks about the
eminency of Christ and like looking at
the things that are happening around the
world and how it lines up with
Revelation and Matthew 24 and Daniel.
So,
this is part two. But, um
>> we don't have part one for you guys, but
if you want to see similar things with
There's a video on Candid Truth under
the live tab called Beast System Rising
and that's really, to me, putting that
together
You know, every time I'm putting stuff
together I feel like God's just guiding
me and I'm like, whoa, and it's kind of
mind-blowing, but we're repeating
history of uh
like the Great Depression and the whole
economy is about to just collapse with
AI and high tariffs and all this stuff.
Like, we're not even ready for what's
about to come and um
that's really what this presentation
here is about is to be ready. And so,
how do we do that and what are we
getting ready for? So,
I'm I'm very excited to get into this.
Yeah, awesome. Well, here we go.
So, Ready or Not.
This is just a little intro before we
expose the cosmic week and really look
at it. So, what we know here is that the
door is going to close, right? We've got
Matthew 24 and so it says, "As in the
days of Noah, so will be at the coming
when Jesus returns, right?" And so, we
can see similar things happening in the
day of Noah.
So, the the door to the ark closed and
the people were still outside waiting
for like a week before it rained.
And our door is going to close, too.
But, we want to know when, right? Like,
that's the big question is when. Yeah.
And one thing I just really want to keep
in mind for all of us in Matthew 24 is
where it says, "No one knows the day or
the hour." And so, we're not time
setting, but we're looking at this
realistically and saying it's very, very
soon and here's why. Amen.
So, this is a quote from The Great
Controversy and I think it's super
important. It says, "Those who refuse or
neglect to know when Jesus' advent is
near, it will be as fatal for us as it
was for those who lived in the days of
Noah not to know when the flood was
coming." That's a good one.
>> So, it's not something that we just want
to neglect.
For sure. So, then down here like, what
does the world think of us? Um I put
this more like for people in my faith.
Uh just me personally, like I'm SDA and
so, I've talked to people who are not
SDA and I'm like, "Hey, you know, what
do you think about the SDA church?" And
they're like, "Oh, man, didn't they have
all those false prophecies and they like
set the return of Jesus and it didn't
happen."
I like, "Yeah, it was kind of like there
was a a huge disappointment, but it's
really misunderstood."
>> You know what's really interesting and
you might be about to say this, but
there wasn't even a such thing as a
Seventh-day Adventist when that
happened. And it was like in newspapers.
It was It was in newspapers that in 1844
Jesus is going to come and it all
started with a a Baptist minister was
studying Daniel
and I I forget which part of Daniel, but
he's studying
a big prophecy that really churches
don't even talk about. And when he timed
it out, he's like, "Whoa, 1844." And at
the time that was like right around the
corner for them. But, Mhm. all faiths
were studying this and believing it. It
got printed in the papers. People were
selling all their lands and farms and
everything. There was a There wasn't
even such thing as an Adventist church
at that time.
That's true. Yeah, yeah. And so, I think
my my takeaway from that though is like
people who belong to our church, they're
really afraid to be like, "Hey, Jesus is
coming soon." Or they're afraid to be
like, "Maybe it could be this year." And
I think a big part of that is they're
they're afraid to be wrong.
Yeah.
>> And so like, I post this up here like,
"What does the world think of us?" The
real answer is like, "Who cares?" Yeah.
You know what I mean? Like, I'm going to
proclaim that he's coming. If I'm wrong,
I'm like happy I'm wrong. Good, there's
more time. Yeah.
>> But, either way like, it's soon.
Yeah.
>> Okay, so
before I get into some of the
quotations I'm going to use, I think
this is something really important to
discuss because a lot of people outside
of my faith, they have told me like, "I
don't even think prophecy is a a thing
anymore. Like, it ended with Jesus or
the early church." And so, I want to
look at the scripture and as to why I
believe there are still prophecies um
and still people who we can call
prophets. So, super quickly we're just
going to run through these. First
Thessalonians 5 says, "Do not despise
prophecies. Test all things, hold fast
what is good." So, like right away that
tells me, if you're not going to despise
something, there's still merit in Yeah,
it has to be there.
Yeah. And then Matthew 24, Jesus is
talking about the signs of the ends of
the age. "Many false prophets will
arise."
Now, if he's warning us that false
prophets are going to arise, clearly
that means there will be true prophets
as well. Yeah. Otherwise, he'd just say
"Avoid all prophets."
Yeah, and it'd be so much easier just be
like, "Don't listen to prophecies."
Yeah. Like, done.
But, instead we have to sit there and
you know, use discernment. So, Amos
I see a typo there. Amos 3:7 says,
"Surely the Lord God does nothing unless
he reveals it to his secret Sorry,
reveals his secret to his servants the
prophets."
>> That's good.
>> And uh
Yeah, yeah. And like, the thing of this
is
God used prophets all throughout time,
right? Like, anytime something changed
with God's people. Moses, like he rose
up Moses. He rose up Abraham. He rose up
Daniel. He rose up Jeremiah. Anytime
something was going to change with his
people. And so like, why at the end of
time would God be like, "Nah, I'm done."
Mhm.
>> Like, I'm I'm not going to give you
anything else. You're good. Right.
I don't know. So, here we go.
First Corinthians
"For we know in part and we prophesy in
part.
But, when that which is perfect has
come, then that which is in part will be
done away with."
Mhm. And so, this here
we we prophesy in part, right? It's like
prophesying is something that
will continue until
that which is perfect has come.
Because then it's done away with. Right.
>> So, until Jesus returns, until time is
perfect, we still prophesy.
And this is another one that kind of
says the same thing as Ephesians 4. "He
gave some to be apostles, some prophets,
some evangelists, some pastors and
teachers for the equipping of the
saints." Like, do we still need
equipping? Yes. "For the work of the
ministry, for the edifying of the body
of Christ, till we all come to the unity
of the faith."
Are we in unity?
We should be.
We should be. We should be, but there's
like a million denominations. Ephesians,
that's definitely New Testament,
definitely, you know, after the Gospels,
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John. So, this
is Christ has already uh died,
resurrected, ascended into the heavens
and it's saying this some will be
prophets. Some prophets.
Absolutely.
Yeah, and then till we come to the unity
of faith and the knowledge of the Son of
God, to a perfect man, to the measure of
the stature of the fullness of Christ.
So, like we know we will not perfectly
reflect Christ's character until he
comes. Like, we're we're working towards
that. That's a process of
sanctification. But, being a an apostle,
a prophet, evangelist, pastor, a
teacher, all these things are going to
be there until the fullness of Christ,
which again, yeah, like you said, it's
Ephesians.
Yeah. There's a couple more.
So, First Corinthians, Paul tells us to
pursue love
and to desire spiritual gifts, but
especially that you may prophesy. Right.
So, like out of all the gifts, he's
saying this is the best because it's not
just for you, it's for the church.
That's awesome.
Yeah, and then Acts. So, this is where
we see that,
um,
after the cross, there were still
prophecies being made. Acts 11, Agabus
prophesies famine. Acts 13,
um,
there were prophets in the Antioch
church. Acts 15, prophets are
encouraging believers. So, that's just
quick. Yeah, you can add,
John the Revelator in there. I mean,
that's as New Testament as you can get.
Yeah, his whole book, like, exactly.
So, then Joel, this one's talked but it
shall come to pass afterward that I will
pour out my spirit on all flesh. Your
sons and your daughters shall prophesy.
Your old men shall dream dreams. Your
young men shall see visions. And also on
my men servants and my maid servants, I
will pour out my spirit in those days. I
will show wonders in the heavens and the
earth, blood and fire and pillars of
smoke. The sun shall be turned into
darkness and the moon into blood before
the coming of the great and awesome day
of the Lord. So, I mean, he's saying
here, sons, daughters, old men, young
men, slaves, men servants, maid
servants, like, it doesn't matter.
Everybody has the gift of prophesying.
He is not, um, focusing on one group.
But then you look at Joel 2:28, and if
you compare that to Matthew 24 and
Revelation 6:12, you will see the exact
same verbage of the sun being turned to
darkness, the moon going into blood. And
cuz some people confuse this. It says
before the great and awesome day of the
Lord. They're like, what is that? Some
people are like, oh, that was when he
was crucified. That was his awesome day.
But like, if you if you look at Matthew
24 and Revelation 6, what it's referring
to is right before Jesus returns. Like,
that is the sign of the coming of the
Son of Man. Right. Is
the sun and the moon. So, clearly it's
saying he's going to have people
prophesying right up until he returns.
Wow.
>> Okay, so,
I just wanted to throw that out there.
And then there's two more.
The dragon was enraged with the woman
and he went to make
Sorry, and he went to make war. Oh, I
typed that wrong. War.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, I was like, was. War with the rest
of her offspring who keep the
commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ.
And then Revelation 19:10 says the
testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
prophecy.
So, he's literally making war with the
people who have the commandments of God
and the spirit of prophecy. Wow, so,
that is crazy because what are the
majority of churches today doing?
They're not keeping the commandments of
God and rejecting prophecy, too.
And even like saying, I don't even want
to read Revelation. Don't read that to
me. I'm not even going to be here for
that. I'm going to be raptured out of
here. All this stuff like, I
I wanted to study like, I wanted to
study with somebody and I was like, I
can I can show you from the word of God,
um, who's identified as the beast, what
his mark is and all that. And they said,
nope, I don't even got to study that.
I'm not going to be here for it. And I'm
like, wow, Satan is is such a master at
deception that he's got Christians
saying, nope, I'm not even going to look
at that book that's a warning about the
end times because
I believe I'm not even going to be here
for it.
Yeah, I said. I've honestly heard that a
lot, too. Mhm. And it kills me because
like the very beginning of Revelation
says you are blessed if you read the
words of this book. And they're still
like, no, it's not for me.
And it also says, basically, I don't
know if it says cursed, but basically
cursed is anyone that adds or takes away
from
this book. And if you're not reading it
all, you're taking away from it.
That's true. That's true. Yeah. I mean,
yeah, they're definitely missing out on
a lot.
So, here, uh, we're just going to talk
about this for a second. The enemy knows
that his time is short. I use say that a
lot on here, uh, but I think something
that we need to recognize is a lot of us
a lot of us don't. Like, the enemy knows
his time is short and we're like, oh,
yeah, Jesus is coming, but soon. Like,
soon could be another 100 years, you
know, because he said soon 2,000 years
ago. So, soon could be anything.
Um,
but my question is like, how does he
know this? So, I guess I'll ask you,
Mikey, like, how does he know his time
is short? How does Satan know?
I think he's studying prophecy more than
we are.
I think he plays
kind of a part in it, too, because
Christ is going to come when the beast
system is set up. And so, Satan has his
agenda for when he's going to set this
whole system up. You know,
he can't just do anything. He has to
work through the agents of this world.
He's
he's the god of this world. That's why
he could offer all the kingdoms of this
world to Jesus and anybody else.
And we battle not against flesh and
blood, but against principalities,
against the powers of the darkness of
this age, all these things. Satan is
working through agents in this world.
Um, but he's been doing it for a long
time and he's he's got his people in
place.
And they're all just pawns and he's
setting up the beast system. So, I
believe he has his own
he's a counterfeiter. All he does is
copies everything God does. God's got
prophecies, he's got his prophecies and
he's got his agenda.
And so, yeah, I think he knows he's got
a short time because
he's kind of
propelling the end, really.
Yeah, for sure. I mean, I agree with
that completely. And he's been here
since the beginning, right? Like, he was
in the garden and he heard when God told
Adam that his seed was going to crush
his head.
Like, if you know somebody's going to
crush your head, don't you want to be
learning how or why or when?
Like, literally his existence depends on
it. So, of course, he takes it more
seriously than we do.
Uh, but yeah, like, he knows prophecy
certainly better than we do because he's
seen it play out from the beginning like
till now. That's right.
>> So, we're going to take a look at some
prophecy and it says for 6,000 years
Satan has deceived the earth.
Mhm.
So, here's we this is where we're going
to deal with the cosmic week of time.
So, for those of you that haven't heard
this, it's titled two different things,
either the cosmic week or the great week
of time. And if you've never heard this
before, it is like truly fascinating.
Basically, what this saying is that just
as God used six days to create the earth
and then he had a seventh day of rest,
that God uses this model for the entire
existence of the earth. So, for 6,000
years,
the earth is going to play out and then
it will end. And then the 7,000th year
is the year of Jubilee, is the year of
rest. It's a thousand year millennial
reign. And so, when we look at this, we
can start seeing like, wow, okay, time
is really short. And so, I tried to make
this graph here. Um, the pictures that
are up there are great, but they don't
really match up the timeline at the
bottom. But if you look at the timeline
at the bottom, it's so it's like
day zero to one is the first thousandth
year. And then one to two is 2,000 years
and that's when Moses
took place, right? And so, from two to
three is the 3,000th year.
Then day three to four
is the 4,000th and that's when Jesus was
on the scene. So, Jesus, um, his time
frame was at the 4,000 year mark.
And then we have four to five, which is
a 5,000th, and then five to six. And
6,000th year is
what we're looking at here, potentially
the time when earth's history will
close. And then that last
day or thousand years is when we have
the New Jerusalem and the saints
reigning with Jesus in heaven.
So, this is just a visual and then we're
going to go into, um, the specifics. So,
what it's also called the great week of
time. And this is a guy named John
Andrews and he wrote this big long
article. It's not his original idea or
anything. It's just something that I
read to study this. And it was written
in 1883.
And so, he just kind of like plays it
out again and says a lot of the same
things. But just as there were six days
of creation and one day of rest,
the, um, law of the land is similar. So,
the Hebrews, they were supposed to grow
on land for six years and then they were
supposed to have a year of rest at the
end. And in that year of rest, they were
supposed to, um,
not grow anything and let the poor in
the land come and glean.
So, it was like a way of God
of teaching the people generosity.
So, he has that in the law of the land.
But then, this is beautiful. So, he also
has the year of Jubilee.
And, um,
the year of Jubilee is actually seven
sevens.
And so, what you have is after, um,
after each
So, they they count. So, like, time
itself was kept by biblical Jubilees.
So, if you're reading the Old Testament,
they'll be like, yeah, in such and such
in the reign of such and such king and
they're like, the fifth Jubilee, this is
what happened.
And so, that's just like how they kept
time is with the Jubilees. But here's
the beautiful part. When I learned this,
I was just like in awe of God. So, the
year of Jubilee
is every 50th year. And what it is is
it's seven weeks of seven.
So, it's like seven times seven is 49.
And then the next day is the next number
is 50. So, the 50th year is the year of
Jubilee.
Now, this is the beautiful thing. When
you read the Old Testament and you study
the Jubilee,
what happens in that year is that all
debts are canceled.
Wow.
>> Uh, all the slaves are set free.
And then here's the best part. So, God
ordained this system that in the year of
Jubilee,
all of the land would be given back to
its rightful owner. So, what this means
is
um if like like like let's say a Jewish
person,
they ended up well, they were Hebrew at
the time. Let's say a Hebrew person,
they ended up like getting in a
financial strait.
What would happen is they would lease
off their land or they would like put a
mortgage on their land so that somebody
else could help pay, you know, like
they're they're renting their land.
But then in the in the 50th year,
whoever had a mortgage going on or if
somebody's land was leased out to
somebody else, that debt would be
canceled and the biblical understanding,
like what it says in the Bible, is that
the reason God did this was so that
his children would always have an
inheritance.
Wow.
>> So that like yeah, like if there was a
Hebrew person that had financial
hardships, it wouldn't then trickle over
to their children. Their children would
still get the inheritance. Yeah, but
like look at this from the big
perspective. So,
our world right now
is not in dominion of Jesus,
unfortunately. Like we know the prince
of the power of the air, right? Yeah.
And he says this is not his kingdom
because Satan is ruling right now.
But what we see is in in the whole
cosmic timeline, the year of Jubilee is
when this earth is taken from Satan.
He's thrown into a prison.
And so, the original owner was Adam,
right? Right.
>> He's the one who had owner. Satan stole
it from him. He had ownership. And so,
what happens in the the year of Jubilee
is God takes ownership back from Satan
and gives it to Adam's seed,
which is Jesus.
Wow. So, it's like oh, it's so beautiful
how like the year of Jubilee, like he
had all this system set up and that's
literally like the model of what's going
to happen at the end of time.
My mind was blown when I read all that.
I was like, oh God, you're so good.
>> never put it together like that before.
Yeah, it's amazing.
Okay, so we're just going to look at
some scripture really quick. And this is
the scripture that shows a thousand
years on earth is like one day
for heaven.
And so, the first one is Psalms 94
and I'm just going to read that from my
Bible that I have here.
It says, "For a thousand years in your
sight are like yesterday when it is
past, like a watch in the night."
So, it's saying a thousand years is like
a watch in the night. I've never heard
that one. That's good.
Yeah, it's good.
And then Revelation 20. I'm not going to
read this one cuz it's just um it's 1
through 6, but this is where Satan is
bound and it says that the saints are
reigning with Jesus for a thousand
years. Right.
>> That's the millennium, right? Like we're
all familiar with that. Yeah. But that
shows that for a thousand years at the
end of time, there's going to be a rest
and that God will have his people with
him.
And then Hosea 6:1-2.
I love this one. This is like one of my
favorites.
Hosea 6
Hosea, Hosea, Hosea
1 and 2
Remember my Bible alert.
So, I'm actually going to turn back to
the screen because it makes more sense
when I read it and you look at this. So,
it says, "Come and let us return to the
Lord, for he has torn, but he will heal
us.
He has stricken, but he will bind us
up." Here it comes. "After two days, he
will revive us."
Mhm. So, Jesus came at year 4,000,
right?
Mhm.
But if we're looking at days, he came on
day four
from a biblical perspective.
After two days is day six. That's the
end. After two days, he will revive us.
On the third day, he will raise us up.
Literally, like that's when the
resurrection happens. And then it says
that we may Yeah, so on the third day,
he will raise us up that we may live in
his sight.
Like that to me is beautiful.
That is amazing. Okay.
Yeah, because like we won't be able to
live with him until the very end. And
it's saying after that third day, we'll
be in his sight. Oh, it's beautiful.
Okay, and then Hebrews 4
1 through 11 just talks about there
being a future rest for God's people.
And so again, like at the cosmic week of
time, we're looking at that last
thousand years as the year of rest. Like
the earth is going to be desolate and it
will be resting just like in the year of
Jubilee how the earth was supposed to be
desolate and resting from growth. Wow.
So, the question is, is it plausible? Is
it plausible for God to ordain 6,000
years for the world to be in this great
controversy plus a thousand years of
rest in heaven? I don't want to derail
this thing and go into the some other
study,
but
the majority of the Christian world
believes that
the thousand-year reign will be on
earth.
But when I read the Bible, I see that
when Christ returns at his second
coming, he doesn't touch the ground.
We're caught up to meet the Lord in the
air and forever remain with him and the
wicked are consumed by the brightness of
his coming. So, who's left on earth?
If the wicked are consumed, the
righteous are caught up to meet him,
it's desolate and you can find that by
going to
Jeremiah. Jeremiah chapter 4 starting
with 23.
And and you read
verses following that, 23, 24, 25, and
it says,
"I beheld and the earth" Are you going
to it now? It's amazing. Yeah, I'm
looking for it. Mhm. So, it says, "I
beheld and the earth, it was without
form and void." And you're like, oh,
this is talking about creation week, but
then it continues and it says
that there was no man, that the cities
were broken down, that the birds had
fled away, and that the whole earth was
desolate. And it's like, wait a minute,
I've never heard
um any I've never heard any sermon on
this. Like, what time period is this
when the earth is desolate and void,
like an abyss?
It's actually using the same word
um that
when Genesis during creation week, when
it says the earth was without form and
void, it's the word
uh it's a Hebrew word that's basically
the same word as abussos, but abussos is
Greek.
And um it's the same word. It means a
void,
uh empty abyss. And and Jeremiah is
saying the same thing, that there's
coming a time
at the Lord's fierce anger
that the earth is going to be desolate,
that cities that men had built are now
broken down, that the birds have fled
away, all this stuff. What is that time
period? That is the time period where
Satan and his demons are bound to this
earth for a thousand years, death row
sentence,
and we are in heaven with Christ for a
thousand years. It talks about "And the
books were opened." I think that's in
Daniel. The books are open. We're going
to get to see
and review the records of all our family
and friends who aren't there.
We're going to wonder, "Why is grandma
not here?"
And it's going to take a while to go
through those records and see, "Okay, I
see that she had a double life" or
whatever.
And then Paul says, "Do you not know
that you will judge angels?" talking
about us. So,
after the thousand years is finished,
after we've gone through all the
records, we will return to earth. That's
why it says Christ with all his saints
are returning to earth. And And in
Revelation, it says,
"And the rest of the dead" Who are
those? I never hear a sermon about that
either. The rest of the dead, that's the
wicked who were consumed at the
brightness of his coming.
The rest of the dead live not until the
thousand years is finished. So, after
this thousand years, there's a
resurrection of those wicked and this is
their judgment. And in that moment,
Satan has a short seat a short little
time to deceive them all into compassing
the city of the saints and trying to
take over the New Jerusalem by force.
And in that moment, we actually see
Wow. Okay, we see their true colors.
Like there's nobody there that's
righteous.
And um and Christ brings fire down from
heaven to destroy them and it's a
painful thing to see our family and
friends be destroyed.
And and then Jesus wipes away all your
tears because we're we're crying. Even
he's crying. It's this the the Bible
says it's um his strange act.
And he wipes away all our tears,
recreates the earth new, and we live on
earth for eternity. But
I know this is going to trigger people.
They're going to think this is
false doctrine that we are in heaven for
a thousand years, but it's the only way
anything makes sense.
Because I never understood why
well, Jesus is going to come, set up a
perfect paradise on earth. We're going
to live with Jesus for a thousand years
and then Satan's going to be loosed to
deceive a number like the sand of the
sea. Wow, it was already hard enough to
get here. Now I'm probably going to end
up being a number like the sand of the
sea that's deceived by Satan.
And people have said, "Well, you know,
in the new the new earth, people are
going to be multiplying, you know,
they're going to be um
families are going to be breeding.
There's going to be new people on earth.
That seed of doubt's going to come in
again and they're going to be the ones
that are deceived." But Jesus
goes directly against that. When they
said, um "This woman, she married, you
know,
her husband died and she married his
brother as the custom was" and so on, 10
or seven times,
"whose wife will she be after the
resurrection?"
And Jesus said, "You you err in the
scripture. You don't understand that we
will not give in marriage after the
resurrection.
So, how can the earth
after the resurrection be being
multiplied with new people who Satan can
deceive.
Nothing about the understanding of
a millennial
perfect peace of millennial earth
makes sense.
Um the only way it makes sense is that
we are
taken up to meet him in the air. We're
we're with him for a thousand years. I
just want to clarify that cuz
you have it on here and it
>> That's a good point. Yeah, it might it
might confuse people.
Okay, so one thing to look at is this
idea of the cosmic week.
It's not new by any means. Like this is
not a modern concept. And so I just
wanted us to take a look at this idea
being in all these different historical
uh writings and having lots of Jewish
roots.
I do want to say with this caveat that I
do not take the Talmud or the Zohar
like
seriously. Like that's not something
that I follow or believe in. Right. It's
just to say that these ideas are here,
too.
Right.
>> the Talmud
um which is if you're not familiar with
the Talmud, it's literally just a Jewish
commentary. Like it they talk about
different dealings like rabbis have and
um they talk a lot about traditions of
the rabbis and how they think the Old
Testament should be lived out. So it's
they don't even it doesn't claim to be
scripture. It's just literally
commentary.
But in there they share that there's
6,000 years of world history followed by
a thousand years of desolation or rest
for the earth, just like you were
saying, Mikey. Wow.
And then the Zohar teaches that each day
of creation is equal to a thousand years
and there's a seventh millennium, which
is the Messianic rest. Now this one is
specially like this is a book of Jewish
mysticism. So I in no way like follow
it. It's that that's the Kabbalah and
all that stuff.
So we don't want to take everything that
those books say literally, but it's kind
of like what you were saying earlier.
Like the devil has a counterfeit. So
Right.
God knows his time frame and he's
telling it to people. Well, I think
Satan knows God's time frame and he's
telling people to be like, "Look, I'm
giving you a prophetic word."
And it's not his own power that he's
sharing. He's just sharing God's wisdom.
Yeah. And then um This might dabble into
conspiracy or something, but I think
Satan kind of has to reveal his plan.
There there's in the Kabbalah and all
that stuff. That's why there's all this
predictive programming and all that
stuff, you know.
For sure. Yeah, that's definitely in the
Kabbalah.
Okay. Um and then early early Christian
writers. So there's an Epistle of
Barnabas.
And they say that this is the guy that
traveled with
Peter Mhm. I don't know. Paul for some
time.
Um but it's not in the canon. So but
anyway, it was written in the first
second century. And it says that um
Jesus finished his work in six days,
which is the 6,000 years.
And then you can see this the other two
is Irenaeus.
And 130 to 202 AD says that creation
days equal historical lengths. And
um
his name I think was Justin. I don't
know why I put just, but Justin Martyr
affirmed also that there's 6,000 years
followed by a millennium. That is wow.
So those are just some historical You
did some research on here.
Yeah, I tried. I mean it's it's good to
know what the Bible says, but it's I
think when you see historical proof for
outside of the Bible, like it also just
shows like, "Hey, you know, this might
hold some weight." Right. You were
talking about this is not a new idea.
It's not just a
you don't have to be an Adventist to
believe this or anything. There's and
I'm actually let's see if I switch.
Yeah, so a lot of people are probably
familiar with this girl, K Pagie.
Um I don't believe everything she says
cuz she's starting to talk about some
stuff I disagree with actually, but
um this was a really good video and
she's talking about a really old Bible
and
or two versions that actually say
something about the age of earth and and
listen to the conclusion she comes to.
This is a standard Holy Bible. It has
the Old Testament, the New Testament,
and the Apocrypha. It was made in 1818.
From Adam unto Christ are 3,974
years, 6 months, and 10 days. And from
the birth of Christ unto this present
year is 1815.
Then the whole sum and number of years
from the beginning of the world unto
this present year of our Lord God 1815
are 5,789
years, 6 months, and the said odd 10
days. And it lists the creation day 4004
BC. Here's my 1863 Cassell Publishing
House Bible. And again, right at the
front, the creation date is 4004 BC.
4004 BC, the date of creation, to the
year that they were writing or editing
the Bible, 1815, was 5,789
years, 6 months, and 10 days. And since
then, it's been 211 years. 2026 is the
6,000th year.
Wow.
That's uh that's pretty deep. Pretty
big.
Yeah. So two 2026 is a 6,000th year and
then
um I had something else on here. You
know, just talking about other sources
that
aren't even Christian like Raelianism.
These are people that believe that
Elohim actually are aliens that seeded
life here on earth and they
they have all these prophecies about um
Jesus Jesus going to return, but he's
going to also return with Buddha and
Muhammad and all these
other ascended master type people
and um and they say that this is going
to happen by 2035. So
there's no real set date on it, but
when I look at like what do the esoteric
world say? What do Christians say?
I don't see
any timeline that goes past like 2035.
2035 is like the latest I've actually
seen.
There's a website called
messiah2030project.com
and this is
this is the thing that I saw years ago
that I said I I rejected at first
because I was like
it seems to take away free will and all
that. But um
they've been actively
press pushing this message for a while
and you can check this out if you want
to. Um messiah2030project.com.
And
um Alice Bailey, which is an esoteric
writer. We don't believe in her
writings, but she was
a channeler and she
talked to, you know, ascended masters
and aliens or whatever.
And she talked about
that the year 2025 was going to be very
significant because it was going to be
this whole shift in humanity of us
entering into the age of Aquarius, the
golden age, and that it was going to be
the externalization of the hierarchy,
which literally is
spiritual beings manifesting in our
world. And what do we see going crazy in
2025 is, "Oh, there's drones flying
everywhere and we don't know what they
are. They're not good, they're not bad.
Just keep going on with life as usual."
Uh the government's saying, "Oh, we
communicate with non-human
intelligences. We don't know if they're
alien, they might be interdimensional
beings." So
there this is really happening. These
things are really happening, not because
this is prophetic writing and we need to
put our trust in it, but because Satan
has an agenda. Satan is giving his
prophets
his prophecies and they're publishing
the prophecies
in hopes to trap people in the New Age
movement and stuff like that.
But 2025 is a very significant. And a
lot of people are familiar with Walter
Veith and he believes in this uh um
cosmic week concept. I won't play the
clip, but you guys can look it up.
He actually does a whole uh presentation
on this very thing. So
that's when I was like
I'm starting to really, you know, think
more about this and
when I just look at what's going on in
the world
I don't see how this could keep going on
for too much longer. Right.
For sure.
I mean just the threat of like a nuclear
war coming, what's going to survive
after that? Right. It's crazy.
Yeah, yeah.
Um so I'm going to go through something
that was really amazing to me.
I I look at a little bit later I'll look
at some prophecies that were made about
again like the cosmic week. But before
we do that, I know a lot of people are
sola scriptura. So they don't want to
hear anything unless it's straight from
the Bible.
And so what I want to show is that God
has a pattern.
And God's pattern is seven. Like
>> Mhm. we see that in the days of
creation, right? Like six days Yeah. of
creation, but it wasn't complete until
he had that seventh day of rest.
And literally one thing that I didn't
actually put in here, but
if we look at like the cycles of time,
we know that we have the month based off
of the moon, right? Mhm. So all of our
monthly cycles are based off of the
moon. And we have our yearly cycles
based off of the sun, right? Because
if you believe it, they say that we go
around the sun.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah. I'm going to say that I will laugh
cuz I know you have got different
beliefs with that. Like I don't know
what I believe.
>> Well, well, the Bible does say
the sun is for days, the moon is for
months, which that's why it's called
moons, months. And and stars are for
seasons. So, he he definitely does have
um
like luminary clock up in the sky.
Yeah. Yeah.
But then like if you think about it, how
do we get the week?
There's literally nothing
that our week comes from except for the
fact that God ordained it at creation.
Right.
>> So, like all of civilization, every
ancient group, like literally all around
the world, everyone is always held to a
7-day week. And there's literally no
reason for it outside of the idea that
God ordained it that way as our creator.
Which is pretty amazing, but
>> amazing. What I want to show here, yeah,
is God literally is obsessed with the
number seven.
Because I did a study about the number
seven in the Bible, and at first I was
like, "Wow, there's quite a few." And
then as I kept going, I was just like
mind-blown how many things that he has
that go with seven.
Okay, so I'll kind of like rapid-fire go
through this cuz there's a lot. But I
just want to explain
the Hebrew word. So, the Hebrew word for
seven is shiva, and it came from the
same root as the word shava, which means
to swear an oath or to bind oneself. So,
in ancient Hebrew thinking, to seven
oneself, which is kind of a weird thing
to say, but what that means
[clears throat] is to make a covenant or
an oath.
And so throughout the Bible, we'll see
that seven is directly tied to covenant,
promise, and divine binding or like
binding oneself to an oath.
And an example of this is Genesis
21:28-31,
where Abraham, this is after God tells
him, like he gives God gives Abraham the
promise, and then what Abraham does in
return is he gives seven lambs to God.
And the place is called Beersheba, which
means the well of the oath. So, he takes
seven knowing that that's binding,
and
he sacrifices it back to God.
And the word beer is um well. So, it
means it means well of the oath because
beer means well in Hebrew.
So, that's just um
something to learn at first.
Um here we go.
So,
rapid-fire. At all the things that have
to do with seven in the Bible. 7 days of
creation, right? God blesses and
sanctifies the seventh day. And then he
goes on to command us to remember the
seventh day.
And he kept it holy.
Then feast cycles are built upon sevens.
We see that in Leviticus 23. The land
rests every seventh year. And then the
Jubilee that we talked about earlier is
7 * 7.
Then Daniel 20 not or sorry, Daniel
9:24-27 says, "Let there be 70 weeks."
There's a 70 weeks prophecy, which is 70
* 7.
Right? There's seven appointed feasts.
Passover, unleavened bread, first
fruits, Pentecost, trumpets, day of
atonement, tabernacles. And these are uh
we'll talk a little bit more about these
later, but
this is something that God had his
people following.
Um so, it's like extremely important for
his system of of worship. So, seven
churches of Revelation. These are like
all from the book of Revelations. Seven
spirits of God, seven lampstands, seven
stars, seven seals, seven trumpets,
seven thunders, seven heads or thorns,
seven last plagues, seven bowls of
wrath, seven angels.
Um in the sanctuary service, we see that
there's a seven-branch lampstand, and
that the high priest goes in and
sprinkles blood seven times on the altar
to purify
um
the altar.
And then the temple, I think itself. And
then in Jericho, there were seven
priests, and they were told to blow
seven trumps trumpets, sorry. There were
seven days where they were marching
seven times around the city on day
seven.
Like he's he's got a pattern here. Yeah.
Forgiveness. We are told in Matthew 18
that we are to forgive 70 * 7 times.
And then in Luke, he says to forgive
seven times in a day.
And then Proverbs 24:8, "A righteous man
falls seven times and rises again."
Proverbs 9:1, "Wisdom builds her house
with seven pillars."
And then Psalms 12:6, "The words of the
Lord are pure words, like silver tried
in a furnace of earth, purified seven
times." So, something about seven is
like completion, you know, purity,
righteousness.
Miracles. Naaman is washed seven times
in the river Jordan to be clean.
>> Yeah. And then in Matthew, there's that
feeding miracle with seven loaves of
bread.
Mary Magdalene had seven demons.
>> Seven demons, wow. It's like
Yeah, like even I think that one's
interesting, but to me what it says is
she was like filled to the brim to the
to like complete fullness of evil, and
God still redeemed her. Wow.
This one's awesome though. Generations.
So, he even showed this pattern in
generations. From Abraham to David,
there are 14 generations, so 7 + 7
generations. And then from David to
captivity in Babylon, there's 7 + 7
generations. And then from the captivity
in Babylon to Christ, there are 7 + 7
generations. And all that's like it
spills it out in Matthew 1:17.
So again, he's just showing
how he uses seven as a pattern.
Um Enoch. We know Enoch, right? He
walked with God. Yeah. He was considered
righteous, and he was literally the only
one that God came and took.
And he's the seventh from Adam. So, like
>> crazy. I never knew that. pattern of
righteousness. Yeah, it's so cool.
This is a new one for me, so
seven statements. So, when Jesus was on
the cross, he only said seven
statements. Father, forgive them. He
told the thief, "You'll be with me in
paradise." He said to John, "Behold your
mother." He said, "My God, my God." He
said, "I thirst. It is finished. And
into your hands I commit my spirit."
Seven statements is all he made on the
cross.
Wow.
>> Crazy, right?
>> That is.
>> And then it throughout all of the New
Testament, he only has seven I am
statements.
What? So, he says, "I'm the bread of
life. I'm the light of the world. I'm
the door. I'm the good shepherd. I'm the
resurrection and the life. I'm the way,
the truth, the life, and I am the true
vine." Seven statements.
>> These are the things that make the word
of God like supernatural because we're
talking about a we call it a book, but
it's 66 books
written by over 40 different authors
from all walks of life, from fishermen
to kings, written over a span of 1,200
years,
and yet
it it's all so perfect, you know? It's
like if if one more author would have,
you know, recounted that Jesus said I am
or whatever, it would have been eight.
It's just crazy. You know what I'm
saying? Like even the people, the
scribes and stuff, if they made one
little jot or tittle wrong, they burned
the whole thing and started over. Like
it was it's so precise, and I
I've went into some of these like Bible
codes and stuff like that. It's pretty
interesting stuff to see
when you when you look at the Hebrew
like every so many letters and stuff
will spell stuff. It
It's just it's a supernatural book all
the way. The living word of God.
Yeah, 100%. Honestly think like the rest
of eternity, we're going to be learning
about all the ways that God ordained
things in the Bible. Like you're saying
like the Bible codes. And half of it's
lost because of we don't know Hebrew.
But someday I think we're going to see
the big picture. We're going to be like
mind-blown every day learning something
new about God and his character.
I'm like pumped.
Okay, I think that was the last seven.
So, now I'm going to look a little bit
at the spirit of prophecy. And for those
of you that are not a part of my faith,
these are by Ellen White, but
I believe that we do have prophets in
the end. And so, I I take her word. And
for those of you that are like, "I don't
know about prophecies,"
my method is like I'll listen to it,
I'll read it, I'll put it on the shelf.
Right.
>> it comes to pass. You know what I mean?
Yeah. Um cuz we're told to test
everything. So, yeah, like don't just
accept it.
Keep it there. But you can't test it if
you don't hear it.
Yeah, if you don't read it. Yeah. So,
honestly, like when I first came to the
SDA church, I was weary because I never
heard of a modern-day prophet, and I was
like, "I I don't know about that." And I
literally asked a bunch of people, and I
heard a ton of different reasons why
SDAs are a cult. Mhm. And I was like,
"Okay, well, we'll see." And then
literally like the internet has all
these quotations taken out of context
and all this stuff, but I was like, "I
don't want to read somebody else's
opinion." So, I literally just started
reading for myself, and I think the
first book I read was Christ's Object
Lessons. Oh, yeah.
>> But literally all I saw in her book was
that she just magnifies the word of God.
Yeah. Like it's literally like reading a
a commentary to the Bible. Just like any
other biblical author. Like you read her
words, and you're like, "Wow, I never
thought about it that perspective." It's
not like she changes the meaning of
things. She just adds to it. Yeah.
>> And so,
I I noticed that too. Like
>> the first thing I ever read one time
because I I love Revelation, and so I
was reading something that she wrote
about Revelation, and
and it started out by saying, "When John
was exiled on that island," and
Revelation talks about that, that he was
exiled to the Isle of Patmos, and then
it just keeps going. Well, she stops you
there, and she's like,
"What what must have he been thinking as
he's, you know, looking
he's surrounded by the depths of the
water, and what kind of creatures are
down there and all this stuff. I'm like,
"Wow, I've never like stopped
on one part and just actually put myself
in the character's shoes."
And that's what she was doing and I was
like, "This is awesome."
Yeah.
Yeah, truly. I love her books, I do, but
I I didn't gain that understanding or
appreciation until I read it for myself.
Yeah. So,
I'm just going to say that, but
if we study through her words um and the
spirit of prophecy, which we know the
Bible says to hold to,
we see there are 42
different statements that say
um historically the world is going to
end in 6,000 years. Wow.
And then there's 41 different statements
that talk about a 4,000-year mark and
what she says is that is that Jesus
um lived until the 4,000-year mark. But
like scholars don't even argue that
point. So, this isn't really something
that's just specific to her. I was just
including that. So, it says, "Do not
forget this one thing, that with the
Lord one day is as a thousand years and
a thousand years as one day."
That's probably like the most clear
scripture we have
uh pointing to the cosmic week. Right.
But I'm going to look at these two these
two um quotations I think are really
great. So, this one she says, "The great
controversy between Christ and Satan has
been carried on for almost 6,000 years
and is soon to close." And yet few have
their attention called to this matter.
And that was written in 1884. [laughter]
>> second one
Yeah, 1884. Yeah, that was a long time
ago.
And then this one is early writings.
This is one of my favorite books, but it
says,
"When the never-ending blessing was
pronounced on those who had honored God
in keeping his Sabbath holy, there was a
mighty shout of victory." So, this takes
place she's saying this is what's
happening
in heaven. And it says, "Then commenced
the Jubilee when the land should rest."
So, here she's just reiterating the fact
that that last thousand years is a
Jubilee where we're with Jesus in heaven
and the earth is laying at rest
desolate.
>> Wow.
So, again I just wanted to reiterate
like scholars totally agree with this.
It's not an SDA thing. Almost all
biblical scholars that are creationists
and not evolutionists, they will say
that 4,000 years into history Jesus
lived. So, that's not really something
that we argue about at all. But the
spirit of prophecy specifically has two
statements. And it's interesting because
she says a couple of times, "At his
baptism, this marks the 4,000-year mark
of of the great controversy. Like it's
been going on for 4,000 years." But she
also makes the statement at the
crucifixion.
And so,
the only little bit of wiggle room we
have if we're following this is that
there's that three and a half years
between his baptism and his crucifixion.
Right.
>> this is this is where it gets
interesting like that video that you
shared. If we count 4,000 years from
Jesus's baptism, which is recorded as 27
AD, what year does that take us to
today? So,
27 plus 2,000, right? It's pretty easy
math. Oh, yeah. Yeah. 2027. Yeah, yeah.
2027. Yeah, so if we look at the close
of the 6,000 years, it could be at 2027.
And you know, I was trying to follow
that video that you shared and I'm like,
"Something about her math ain't mathing
and I can't figure out how she got to
2026." I'm terrible at math, so I
couldn't follow along, but I just
thought it was interesting.
Well, I didn't like I didn't take the
time to actually run through her
numbers, but a lot of people forget that
when time was changed, so Mhm. like
when it went from
BC to AD, Yeah. people forget that there
was no year zero. Right.
So, that actually
like you have to add that year in. So,
maybe that's how she missed 2026 to
2027. I don't know. Yeah, maybe. It's
interesting though.
Yeah, so but the other thing is if we
count 4,000 years from his crucifixion,
that'd be three and a half years later.
So, it could be 2027
if we're looking at his baptism. But if
we're looking at his crucifixion, three
and a half years later, that would take
us to 2030.
And what I find interesting about that
is like on the cross Jesus said, "It is
finished."
Like that's the part that's the like
that point in his ministry where he
defeated Satan. So, in my mind like
that's more of a marker than anything
else. Like yeah, he started his ministry
in 27, but I'm personally am more apt to
believe that it's more or less his
crucifixion that is the 4,000-year mark.
Oh, wow. Okay.
>> And that's just like me.
That's just me being personally biased.
I don't I don't have anything to share
with that,
but that's my thought. Like
>> that yeah, you think it's three and a
half years later than
his baptism, but I still have three and
a half years. I mean, that goes by so
fast.
Right, like small window, teeny tiny
window.
Here's something that might blow your
mind. My husband and I literally were
just talking about this today. So, we
know that the Bible says, "As in the
days of Noah, right?" So, will it be at
the end of the age? Like they'll be
eating and drinking and getting married
and building and all these things. Well,
if you look at the story of Noah,
he literally started building the ark
and was telling people like cuz they're
like, "Noah, what are you doing? You're
building an ark in the desert. Like it
doesn't even rain. What are you doing?"
And he's like,
"God's going to do something big. Like
the flood's coming." And I mean, we can
always realize that they're going to
call him crazy, right? Like that's just
the natural reaction.
And so, for 120 years, like that blows
my mind. 120 years he built the ark.
Wow. And that entire time he's given the
warning.
And he's telling them, "There's a flood
coming. Like
prepare." And I'm sure they just made
fun of him the whole time like
ridiculing him like, "Oh, he's wasting
his time. He's wasting money." Whatever.
120 years the message went out and
nobody heeded it. Like
it's actually so tragic. The only people
that got on the boat were his family.
There were eight people on the boat.
Yeah. It's sad. But get this. Get this.
So, those of you watching, if any of you
in the SDA faith, you're going to
appreciate this so much.
Literally the last public
prophecy that Ellen White had
was 1910.
1910.
Add 120 to that.
You know what year you get to?
19 2030. Oh, wow. Yeah.
So,
>> 2030. So, yeah. So, you're saying 120
years, yeah, like Noah had 120 years.
So, she was get she's been giving
prophetic messages and then she dies and
there's 120 years for people to like
heed to that message. But how many
people are actually going to get on
before 2030 comes?
Right. Right. I don't know.
Literally that we we were just talking
about that today. I'm like, "I'm just
going to share that with people." Like I
didn't even know, but it could be it
could be That is interesting. Okay.
So, this is something that I think we
all need to like
it's it's easy to set dates and it's
easy to be like, "Man, the world needs
to know." But
what God keeps telling me to do is like
look inward, right? So, we know that it
says God will cut time short in
righteousness.
Like it literally says if he doesn't cut
time short, no flesh will be saved. Mhm.
Like we don't know what that means. Like
it's still up to God. God is God. He can
do whatever he wants. But the question
is like God keeps putting on my heart is
like, "What is he waiting for?"
Right? Yeah.
And clearly like I mean, I I have a nice
AI picture here to show you, but like
he's waiting for his bride. He's waiting
for his bride to be ready. Right.
>> And so, like the church
the church is not my denomination. The
church is literally like every worldwide
believer that has faith in Jesus Christ.
We are the body of Christ. We are the
church of Christ.
>> Amen. And so, he is waiting for all of
us. Like it says that he is not slack in
his promises, but that he is patient
because he does not even want one person
to perish. Amen. And so, what he's
waiting for is us. Like legitimately, if
if we were to
David Gates, I love David Gates and he
put it this way. He said, "If you were a
man standing at the altar and your bride
walked down and you're like, 'Oh, are
you ready? You're ready to get married?'
And she was like, 'Uh yeah, but I'm in
love with somebody else. I'm in love
with another man.'
Like who would be like, 'Yeah, let's get
married, right?'" Yeah. But here we are
like God's bride, Christ's bride, and so
many of us are still in love with the
world. Wow. Like as much as we say we're
not, we are, you know? Like there's
beautiful things in the world. It's hard
to let go of the only thing we've known.
But like God's waiting. He's waiting for
us to truly be ready and to take the
Bible seriously.
Yeah, I remember when I was still living
like the world as a self-professed
Christian, I
I had no desire for Christ's return. I
was like, "I'm having fun." Whatever,
but
every day that comes by like when I have
worship in the mornings with my wife and
we pray together and stuff,
I'm literally praying like, "Lord, come
soon." And the only thing that makes me
hesitate to say that is thinking about
people who aren't ready.
And maybe even myself, you know, I don't
even know if am I ready?
But I'm just so done with this world.
I'm so done with it.
There's nothing this world has to offer
me that is worth missing out on eternity
and I've I've experienced so many things
this world has nothing. I'm so done with
it.
Me too. Amen. Amen.
So I just put this on there as a a way
to convict each of us.
If you're comfortable in your walk with
Christ, I dare say it's because you've
compromised.
>> Mhm. I put that as a quote because it it
resonates better when it's a quote, but
that's by me. Oh, good. I'm un-famous.
So there you go.
All right. All right. So
I was waiting for you to catch up.
Here's where it gets interesting. All
right. So maybe some of you have have
heard about the cosmic week.
Maybe you have. Maybe you haven't. Maybe
you've never realized that literally
that 6,000 year mark could have end at
2027. It could end at 2030. But again,
like that's such little wiggle room. If
we have 1 year left, if we have 3 years
left, like that's nothing. You know what
I mean? Like we got to we got to get our
lives in order today.
>> told by a doctor you got 3 years to
live, 3 and 1/2 years to live. I mean
That's terrifying.
Yeah, sobering. Yeah. But
that's each of us.
Okay. So I'm going to look at something
a little bit different and um I'm hoping
that everybody can listen with an open
heart and just get the entire message
that I'm trying to share. So what we
know in the Bible, it's in Daniel 7. It
says it's talking about the antichrist
system, right? He shall speak pompous
words against the most high, shall
persecute the saints of the most high,
and shall intend to change times and
law. Then the saints shall be given into
his hand for a time and times and half a
time.
So we know at the end what he's going to
do is intend to change the times and the
law. So Mikey, when you when you hear
that, what law do you think of that the
enemy has
very much changed?
>> The 10 Commandments.
For sure, right? Like the Catholic
Church took the 10 Commandments and
switched them around. Like they actually
have nine that
and they split the last two up, right?
And if we look at the majority of the
world,
they don't hold to the Sabbath, which is
the fourth commandment. Mhm. They take
they take God's commandment and they put
in place of it a tradition of man,
Right.
>> which is the first day of the week. Like
there's nothing in the Bible that tells
us to to go to church on Sunday. Mhm.
But there we go. Like the law has been
changed. Um but the interesting thing is
what does time mean when we're looking
at time according to the Bible? And so
when we look in the Old Testament, we
see God's appointed times. Mhm.
>> And Leviticus 23, we see that God has
ordained appointed times. And these are
not festivals like the way that we
understand them. The Hebrew word is
moed, which means appointed times or
specific times when God meets with his
people. And like that's a big statement
that I want us to really digest. It's
not just a time where
he he set up all these ordinances for no
reason.
>> Right.
>> These are the times when God wanted to
meet with his people.
And so on the left there, I just have
like um just a a quick overview, but
we'll look at them closer.
And it's
>> actually open Leviticus 23, sorry. I was
just going to say it is weird how
how serious we take certain dates. You
know, like you miss your wife's
anniversary or something, it's that's a
bad thing or birthday or whatever.
Even when you stop doing the holidays
and stuff and people are like, "What?
How are you not going to do Christmas or
something?"
It's like why is this date so important
to you? December 25th, why is that so
important? But then we're like, "Oh, you
can keep the Sabbath any day. It's not
important, you know."
Pretty important. I mean, it was written
in stone with God's own finger with the
word remember in front of it.
Uh that's more important than some
tradition, for sure.
Absolutely.
Absolutely. Interesting enough though,
like when you look at Leviticus 23, like
the entire chapter is just talking about
his feasts. But the first thing like the
first appointed time that he describes
is the Sabbath. So it says God set it
apart and made it holy for the purpose
of communion and fellowship with God.
It's like God's setting that reoccurring
appointment with us on his calendar.
Like which is huge. He's like, "Hey,
these are the times I want to spend time
with you." And we're like, "Nah. Yeah.
>> I'll do it on my own time, you know?
Like it's sad. It is. So then it says
that the feasts are commanded to be
observed as a statute forever or an
everlasting ordinance, which means that
they're not intended to change or lose
their significance over time. Mhm. Now
one thing that I've heard is like the
word forever has different meanings in
in biblical terms, right? And so some
people will say, "Well, the Levites,
they were told to be they were like um
I forget the word it is, but it's like
they were told that they were going to
be priests forever for God." But really
their priesthood ended at their death.
Right.
>> So sometimes the word forever means like
until that thing has ended. Yeah. It's
any span of time until completion. Any
any span of time until completion.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And so people will say,
"Well, the feasts
um ended because the Hebrew nation is no
longer under God." But my personal
thought with that, and again, this is
just my opinion,
when we look at the Church of God, what
we see is that the Jewish nation
they
at the end of Jesus' ministry, like when
when Stephen was stoned, right? That
says that the Jewish nation rejected God
and finally he said, "I'm now rejecting
you." And so that's when Paul came into
the picture and then the Gentiles had
the opportunity to receive salvation.
But like the big thing is like did did
God come and say, "Okay, I'm taking an
axe to that tree. Forget that tree. I'm
going to cut I'm I'm going to plant a
new seed and grow a new tree."
Mhm. He doesn't say that.
He says we are grafted in to the old
tree. Right.
And so does that nation quit or are we
now the continuation of God's chosen
people? Yeah, there's neither Jew nor
Greek. We're all one in Christ Jesus.
We're all heirs according to the
promise. We're all seeds of Abraham and
heirs according to the promise. We are
Israel and
yeah, people always like to use these
terms to to try and stigmatize
certain theology. Like they'll say like,
"Oh, you believe in soul sleep or
whatever. You're a conspiracy theorist."
Just because you ask questions. And so
they'll call it replacement theology.
"Oh, you believe in replacement
theology?" It's like replacement. I
mean,
Jesus is the one that
or we're we're told right there in the
Bible that there's neither Jew nor
Greek. We're all one in Christ Jesus.
That's not my theology or my words. It's
right there in the Bible. Circumcision
is nothing.
Um all these things. I don't think that
Honestly, I don't really think it was
ever about a nation. I think it was
that that was particularly the people
who worshiped God and believed in God,
but anyone could be
a Christian. Anybody could become a
believer in God. It didn't depend on
where you were physically,
geographically at on this earth.
Uh the gospel, the salvation's always
been for everyone.
Yeah, 100%. And like if it wasn't,
the line of Jesus wouldn't even be
intact because we know that Rahab, she
wasn't Hebrew. Yeah. And like she's in
the line of David, the line of Jesus.
Ruth is like the great grandmother to
David.
Or really?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So he's not a
respecter of persons. Specter of
persons. He definitely just
um
keeps the people who who keep his
commandments.
My screen is frozen.
Here we go.
Okay. So I'm going to look at this a
little bit more. So the ceremonial
system was made up of symbols pointing
to Christ
to sacrifice and his priesthood. This
ritual law with sacrifices and
ordinances what was to be performed by
the Hebrews until type meant antitype
Mhm. and the death of Christ, the lamb
of God that takes away the sin of the
world. And I mean, I agree with this
fully. And then after Jesus as the lamb
of God took away the sin of the world,
all sacrificial offerings were to cease.
>> Amen.
>> And that's from The Great Controversy.
And then we know that in the past only
the high priest could enter the holy
place where God's Shekinah glory rested
above the ark of the covenant. And um
I love this picture here cuz it shows
that that curtain was torn like right as
Jesus was killed. It says, "But now we
can come before God's throne of grace
through the
tiation, which means the complete
removal of our sin. So we no longer need
priests or high priests to mediate for
us because a greater high priest has
been given.
But again, my question is like what
ended here? Does it say that like all of
the feasts ended here? We're not even to
pay attention to feasts anymore? Or is
it just the sacrificial system?
Like the one thing that we can say for
certain is that the Bible says he was
our Passover lamb. Right. Bible says he
was our Passover lamb. Right. But
nowhere does it But nowhere does it say
like stop paying attention to my
appointed times.
Right. And And so here's [clears throat]
where I think it's interesting. Anything
in the word of God it says and And so
here's where I think it's interesting.
Anything in the word of God it says um
you know, it talks about the blood of
bulls and goats does not satisfy God and
all this stuff like stuff like that's
what we're told specifically
um not to do. That's what we're told
specifically
um not to do.
Yeah, so that's it's like all this
slide. You're so good Mickey.
>> Oh, good. So here um Jesus like this is
how important I think the biblical
feasts are to God. Because what we see
is that God set up a pattern and his
pattern was to have these appointed
times. And actually I was reading this
with my my 8-year-old boy. He's got
these um they're amazing facts
like it's amazing facts kids Bibles but
they're got tons of stories. And one of
the things that we noticed was that God
continually every time his people came
back from captivity
one of the first things that he would
have he would have his people do is
go back to um
honoring past people do is
honoring past the point where a king
Hezekiah actually
hears from the Lord and he's told to
keep past hears from the Lord and he's
told to keep Passover and then he gives
this invitation to all of
uh Jerusalem. He invites all the tribes
to Jerusalem and says, "Come to
Jerusalem. Let's celebrate Passover
together. We can unite as a
brotherhood." And literally only one
tribe came. But they came and celebrated
Passover and they hadn't done so in
decades. And what happened after that
was after that tribe Well, first of all,
they loved it so much they ended up
celebrating it for an additional week.
So they didn't stay for 1 week, they
stayed for two. And then um after that
those two weeks on their way home it
said that they tore down every idol,
every altar, everything that no longer
coincided with the way of God. So like
returning to the Passover for them was
returning to God.
Um
and I have this like I didn't include in
here I could have but there's a table of
all the times that after the God's
people returned from exile he had them
again keep the Passover. And like this
is important for God's people because
imagine if
they'd forgotten all the different
aspects of Passover. When Jesus came
they wouldn't have recognized him for
what it was, right? Right.
But this is the the big picture that I
want us to see.
God didn't have have to complete
anything on a feast timeline. But Jesus
died literally on the 14th of Nissan or
Nisan, which is the preparation day
before the high pass sorry, the high
Sabbath which is Passover. We know that
the um Jewish people the day starts in
the evening, right? As soon as sundown
hits the new day starts. So the very
moment that Passover starts that's when
the Hebrews are told to um slay the
lamb. Mhm. And so Jesus was literally
slain on the cross the exact time that
the lambs were being slain.
Which is amazing like
I it wasn't even his own doing that he
was killed. Like the evil people of the
age did that. He had no control over
when he was killed but even even in that
like God ordained for that to happen.
Um and again so like it's explained the
blood of bulls and goats can't take away
is just a teaching tool.
And that shows us yeah, that like the
animal offerings received
Sorry, those who brought animal
offerings forgiveness of sins not
because of the animal's blood itself but
because it pointed to Jesus.
>> Amen. So again
it's not bound by time. Before Jesus
even came and died his sacrifice was
already being applied to those before
Jesus who had faith in what Jesus was
going to do.
So the animal sacrifices were just a
symbol pointing to the greater reality.
>> always been faith. It's either faith the
faith in the future Messiah that they'd
never seen before and for us it's faith
in the past Messiah.
Only very few people within 33 years
even got to be in his presence.
Um but it's always faith.
So this is the one I think that I I
really want to share. I'm hoping people
can accept this.
Even people who say like the feasts have
been fulfilled in Christ Mhm. what they
agree upon is that all of the spring
feasts have been fulfilled.
Mhm. The spring feasts were about his
his crucifixion, the fact that he was a
Passover lamb. But the fall feasts
actually we are still waiting for
fulfillment. And so we look at the day
of atonement, right? Um